and unemployment benefits are in
jeopardy tonight since the federal
government has yet to come to
any agreement on a relief bill as kate
houston reports for us this delay could
impact hundreds of
thousands of nevadans theater officials
say they were fully prepared to
implement the covet 19 relief bill
but now their hands are tied without a
signed bill
deter says they cannot extend
unemployment benefits for nevadans that
desperately need them
it will affect hundreds of thousands of
nevadans
moving forward if the bill is not signed
unemployment benefits will expire this
saturday for nearly 200 000 people
this applies to pandemic unemployment
assistance pandemic emergency
unemployment compensation
and state extended benefits due to the
delay from the federal government there
could now be a delay in payments once a
bill is passed
at this point it is
a virtual certainty that there will have
to be some gap in benefits
when this bill is signed the department
says nevada families are about to face
unbelievable hardship if action is not
taken i urge
congress and the president to think
about the families about to lose their
homes and their ability to support their
children
and resolve this crisis if the bill is
signed the department of labor says it
could still take about two weeks to
provide guidance to the state
deter will then have to review it and
make sure they're properly implementing
the program
in the meantime dieter is asking
nevadans and the regular ui program
to continue to file weekly benefits they
want to reassure pua claimants that they
will be able to catch up on weeks that
they were not able to file
due to the delay kate houston 8 news now
and this is new at 6 governor sisilak
expressing his displeasure
at this latest turn of events tweeting
in part i was already frustrated with
the late timing of this stimulus bill
but that frustration has
only grown now that the president has
created immense uncertainty
on the future of this federal funding
the governor going on to say here his
inaction in guardsmanship gamesmanship
that is
has put nevada in states all across the
nation in an impossible situation
unfortunately and despite deter's hard
work nevadans will suffer because of the
failures in washington d.c
to act in a timely manner